Vor ein paar Tagen
haben wir über Uber Eats berichtet.
Der Beitrag fand bei vielen Anklang
und uns erreichten viele Fragen.
Wir haben ein paar dieser Fragen
herausgepickt
und werden sie jetzt
für euch beantworten.
"Wie viele Kilometer
hast du im Durchschnitt
pro Arbeitseinsatz gemacht?"
"Warst du nicht total erschöpft
vom Velofahren?"
Nein, vom Velofahren
war ich nicht total erschöpft.
Ich mochte es sogar.
Einige Strecken waren tatsächlich
z.T. sehr anstrengend,
z.B. Richtung Zürichberg.
Aber unter dem Strich
habe ich es sehr gern gemacht.
Pro Arbeitseinsatz habe ich
zwischen 8 und 10 km zurückgelegt.
Das Problem war -
und das hat mich genervt -,
dass es praktisch nie die 1 bis 3 km
bis zum Restaurant waren,
wie eigentlich versprochen wurde.
Also die Fahrt, die im Grunde
genommen nicht bezahlt ist.
Es waren immer viel mehr Kilometer.
Es gab solch absurde Aufträge wie:
6 km bis zum Restaurant -
in diesem konkreten Fall
zu McDonald's -,
und der Auslieferort
befand sich 200 m daneben.
Da habe ich
praktisch nichts verdient.
Viele fragten, weshalb wir
Uber Eats so kritisieren würden.
Es sei doch ein Studentenjob,
ein Nebenjob.
Ein- und Ausstieg seien
total flexibel. Das sei cool.
Ja, das ist cool als Arbeit.
Ich habe das auch gerne gemacht.
Ich empfand es fast schon
wie ein Spiel.
Es ist ähnlich wie Geocaching.
Bei diesem Spiel
muss man etwas in der Stadt suchen,
und wenn man es gefunden hat,
erhält man den nächsten Auftrag.
Ja, Uber Eats
hat etwas Cooles an sich.
Die App funktioniert tipptopp.
Das alles ist absolut in Ordnung.
Aber wenn man sich bewusst macht,
dass ein milliardenschwerer Konzern
dahintersteckt,
man selbst aber weder versichert ist,
noch Anspruch auf
Sozialversicherungsleistungen hat,
dann frage ich mich schon:
Möchte ich so etwas unterstützen?
Dann finde ich es nicht mehr so cool.
Und weniger cool ist auch, dass man
sehr abhängig ist vom Unternehmen.
Sie sagen mir,
wann ich einen Bonus erhalte.
Sie sagen mir, wann ich fahren soll,
indem sie mir Anreize schaffen.
Sie sagen mir,
dass, wenn ich Aufträge ablehne,
ich in Zukunft
weniger häufig gefragt werde.
Zumindest habe ich das so erlebt,
Uber selbst bestätigt das nicht.
Es gibt im Hintergrund ein Ranking
und man weiss nicht,
wie der Algorithmus einen einordnet.
Das sind alles Sachen,
über die ich nicht Bescheid weiss.
Ich bin dem Unternehmen ausgeliefert
und ich habe nicht
den Handlungsspielraum,
den das Unternehmen
eigentlich suggeriert.
"Weshalb weigern sich AHV und Suva,
die Fahrer zu versichern?"
Die Schweizerische
Unfallversicherungsanstalt Suva
akzeptiert diese Fahrer nicht.
In der Schweiz ist es so,
dass alle Arbeitnehmenden
unfallversichert sind,
wenn sie angestellt sind.
Oder sie können sich
selbst unfallversichern,
wenn sie selbstständig sind.
Das Problem bei den Uber-Fahrern ist,
dass sie weder angestellt,
noch selbstständig sind.
Bei der AHV verhält es sich gleich.
Die AHV akzeptiert nur Personen,
die tatsächlich selbstständig
oder angestellt sind.
Alles, was dazwischen liegt ...
Z.B. ist auch ein Hausmann oder
eine Hausfrau nicht AHV-versichert
und hat auch
keine Unfallversicherung.
Bei den Uber-Fahrern
verhält es sich gleich.
AHV und Suva
akzeptieren die Fahrer nicht.
Das Hauptargument
für die Ablehnung ist,
dass jemand,
der tatsächlich selbstständig ist,
mehrere Auftraggeber hat. Das ist
bei den Uber-Fahrern nicht der Fall.
Es handelt sich hier also
um eine Schein-Selbstständigkeit.
Aus diesem Grund versichern AHV
und Suva die Uber-Fahrer nicht.
Dazu gab es noch mehr Fragen.
So fragte jemand: "Wer haftet denn
bei einem Verkehrsunfall,
wenn der Fahrer
nicht versichert ist?"
Die Beantwortung dieser Frage
ist nicht so einfach.
Einerseits bin ich keine Juristin,
andererseits ist es
je nach Fall unterschiedlich.
Fakt ist, dass alle Uber-Fahrer nicht
gegen Berufsunfall versichert sind,
da Uber die Fahrer
so nicht versichert.
Uber hat seit knapp einem Jahr eine -
ich nenne es mal -
Unfallversicherung light.
Unsere Juristen
der Konsumentensendung "Kassensturz"
haben sich das angeschaut und sagen,
dass es zwar
eine Art Versicherung sei,
aber die Leistungen
seien völlig unklar.
Mir persönlich
sagte die Dame im Uber-Büro,
als ich mich erkundigte,
wie ich denn versichert sei:
Sollte ich nun hier herausspazieren
und einen Unfall haben,
sei ich nicht versichert.
Niemand würde etwas bezahlen.
Aber sie habe gehört,
dass es z.B. 1'000 Fr. gebe,
wenn jemand Vater werde.
Die Leistungen dieser Versicherung
sind also eine Art Blackbox.
Sicher ist, dass nur etwas
bei Fahrunfällen bezahlt würde.
Alles rund ums Fahren herum
ist nicht gedeckt.
Der Weg zur Arbeit z.B.
ist nicht versichert.
Bei einem Unfall
zahlt also im Grunde genommen
die Kranken-Zusatzversicherung.
Diese Leistungen
sind sehr viel geringer
als bei einer
Berufsunfallversicherung.
Hat man keine Zusatzversicherung -
am Ende wird jemand dafür aufkommen,
wir leben ja in der Schweiz:
die Allgemeinheit.
"Weshalb ist es nicht verboten?"
"Weshalb ist dieses Geschäftsmodell
in der Schweiz erlaubt?"
Es ist erlaubt,
weil Verfahren hängig sind.
Es gibt bisher
kein rechtsgültiges Urteil,
das Uber dieses Geschäft offiziell
erlauben oder verbieten würde.
Aktuell gibt es also Streitparteien.
Abschliessend wurde diese Frage
gerichtlich noch nicht geklärt.
Bis das geklärt ist,
kann Uber weitermachen,
ist dieses Geschäftsmodell
nicht verboten.
Dann hat jemand noch gefragt,
ob dieser Job meine Sicht auf
Essensbestellungen verändert habe.
Ja, das hat er tatsächlich.
Und zwar in vielerlei Hinsicht.
Einerseits habe ich
zum ersten Mal gemerkt, wie es ist,
einen Job auszuüben,
bei dem man gewissermassen
auf der untersten Stufe angekommen
ist - so zumindest mein Eindruck.
Z.T. wird man kaum beachtet,
z.T. gibt es gute Gespräche.
Aber irgendwie
leistet man unsichtbare Arbeit.
Als die Person,
die das Essen liefert.
Was meine Sichtweise
auch verändert hat:
Ich hatte genug von diesem
ganzen Essen, von diesen Gerüchen.
Von diesem Thai-Food,
diesen Pizzen in diesen Behältern,
die das Essen warmhalten sollen -
und wenn man nach Hause kommt,
riecht der ganze Rucksack danach.
Ich hatte keine Lust mehr darauf.
Aber klar,
wenn man etwas lange macht,
verleidet es einem meistens überall.
Dann wurde noch gefragt,
wie Uber Eats denn
im Vergleich zu EAT.ch abschneidet.
EAT.ch ist einer der ganz grossen
Essenslieferdienste.
Ich muss zugeben,
dass ich nicht im Detail über
dieses Unternehmen Bescheid weiss.
Ich habe schon Verträge gesehen,
kenne ihr Geschäftsmodell.
Im Unterschied zu Uber
sind die Fahrer dort angestellt.
Aber sie sind nicht
direkt bei EAT.ch angestellt,
sondern arbeiten
mit sog. Subcontractors.
Sie arbeiten also
mit Firmen zusammen,
die die Arbeit übernehmen.
In unterschiedlichen Regionen
sind das andere Firmen,
und die Fahrer
sind bei diesen Firmen angestellt.
Die Fahrer verdienen nicht viel, sie
werden auch pro Lieferung bezahlt.
Sie haben aber einen Grundlohn
und sind angestellt.
Sie haben also
Versicherungsleistungen,
sind unfallversichert.
Das ist der grosse Unterschied.
Aber der Verdienst
ist auch dort nicht hoch.
Dann wurde auch gefragt,
wie viel Trinkgeld ich bekommen habe.
Ich habe lediglich einmal
Trinkgeld erhalten.
Zu Beginn habe ich
auch nicht begriffen,
wie ich überhaupt
Trinkgeld erhalten kann.
Aber ich hatte schon
mit Trinkgeld gerechnet.
Bei den ersten Lieferungen
gab es kein Trinkgeld.
Trinkgeld gibt es nicht in Form von
Bargeld, sondern direkt über die App,
wenn der Kunde
mit der Lieferung zufrieden war.
Bei einer Pizzalieferung
in ein Hotel in Zürich
habe ich Trinkgeld erhalten.
Es war ein Kunde aus Singapur.
Wir haben uns
noch lange zusammen unterhalten.
Er gab mir 5 Fr. Trinkgeld.
Das war's. Danke für eure Fragen
und Kommentare.
Ich würde mich freuen,
wenn ihr weitermacht.
Insbesondere
würde mich interessieren,
welche Erlebnisse
andere Fahrerinnen und Fahrer
mit Kurierdiensten hatten.
Nicht nur mit Essenskurierdiensten,
sondern grundsätzlich.
Egal für wen ihr gearbeitet habt,
mich interessiert,
welche Arbeitsbedingungen
ihr hattet oder habt.
Dieser Kanal hier
bringt immer wieder Neues.
Es lohnt sich,
diesen Kanal zu abonnieren.
Aktiviert die Glocke,
dann verpasst ihr sicher nichts.